heals Ventures is an early stage
investment and we invest you know from
from day one basically from idea uh in
digital Health uh but we are more on the
Deep Tech side of digital health so
digital Health could be you know
Wellness um phone apps um you know very
easy stuff to develop uh we choose to go
to the medical devices area so doing
Diagnostics doing digital therapy um all
the Deep stuff that takes a lot of time
to develop and it's under regulation so
most of it will be considered a medical
device even if it's just software it
still needs to go through FDA
process um in order to be able to go to
market so in in our field time to Market
is pretty long it's not like you develop
your MVP in two years and you can go to
market no in two years you start
clinical trials in order to validate
your product and then in four to 5 years
you can go to
[Music]
market Tor saxs welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for joining me
today h really excited to dive into your
world dive into the world of of Health
tech and and ealth Ventures um really
curious to get your perspective on the
landscape and the industry and where
we're at the the incredible
opportunities you have a lots of of
experience with various companies and
you've seen a lot you've done a lot so
I'm really curious to sort of do a deep
dive into your mind over 20 short but
meaningful minutes and uh and tell your
story all right uh so thank you for
having me it's really exciting for me to
to do it um so you know I I was born and
raised in Israel in a small town named
ofakim that became famous recently with
unfortunate reasons as you can imagine
um I got into Health Tech by mistake you
know I had um a startup back in 2001
that was dealing with internet stuff
early days that collapsed with the dot
crisis then I had to find a job so I
found a job for a company that developed
Services uh for healthare providers in
Israel and and then it all
started um and it really got bigger and
bigger and after a year or two I I left
the company I opened my own startup in
healthtech for the first time run it for
two years it was pretty
successful um I was successful in
everything except for one important
factor which is choosing the
partner um so we had to split I came
back to the same company I was working
for this time as a partner and and we
started a new company that focused on
the US market so from
200 7 to 12 I was working mostly in the
US around Healthcare around the
healthcare you know it but also devices
tele medicine the early
days and so forth in 2012 I decided that
I want to cross the lines to become an
investor uh I took the first shot failed
which is
good um because again I had to find a
job job and I found a job working for a
different company that was a global
company that focused on Europe more than
the us so I got to learn that the world
is not only the us there is more to it
and in some cases you can do excellent
business in other markets of products
you can sell in the US um in
2015 um I took another shot at the
establishing a VC fund this time I went
back to makabi H services that were my
longtime
client and my partner Steve Shapiro in
the US went to the cland clinic and
together we built the Anor for the the
fund ealth Ventures as it is
today so the transition from the from
the entrepreneurial side to the
investment side what what what was the
trigger for that for you um working in
the US um it was interesting times you
know we had this crisis the financial
crisis of 2008 I just finished my MBA
that was focused on Corporate
Finance um and I found myself giving a
lot of advice to other Israeli startups
who wants to go and start working in the
US and I realized I have a strong point
that I know the US market I know I can
speak both languages the business
language and the technical language uh
so I I I can make the right connections
and help them
and you know pry pry much it's attracted
me more than having another startup so
this is why I made a change and if
you're if you had to map for me the
different elements within Health Tech um
and the opportunities what are what are
some of the the most pertinent problems
that you're that you really excited
about so if you're looking at it now
from from a bird's eye view in your own
perspective what what are the what are
the sort of the verticals or the areas
which you you you are most attracted to
or drawn to yourself mhm so heals
Ventures is an early stage investment
and we invest you know from from day one
basically from idea uh in digital Health
uh but we are more on the Deep Tech side
of digital health so digital Health
could be you know Wellness um phone apps
um you know very easy stuff to develop
uh we choose to go to the medical
devices area so doing Diagnostics doing
digital therapy um all the Deep stuff
that takes a lot of time to develop and
it's under regulation so most of it will
be considered a medical device even if
it's just software it still needs to go
through FDA
process um in order to be able to go to
market so in in our field time to Market
is pretty long it's not like you develop
your MVP in two years and you can go to
market no in two years you start
clinical trials in order to validate
your product and then in four to five
years you can go to
market um so it's a little bit different
than other markets that are faster um in
digital Health we have a few companies
in our portfolio that are you know
software companies that are corporate
software but you know by chance in
healthcare so they can be faster into
the market and the challenge today for
the um startups that develop the
deep Tech side of things that most
investors will not
wait and they don't have the patience to
wait for you to start generate revenue
and you need to show that you have a
running business today that create
revenues for a lot of these startups
it's it's really hard to Gap these
years and so what what are so if you had
to look at the the pain points that that
the your portfolio or the companies that
you're looking at are are tackling
um it sounds like they're they're T
you're tackling more more more deep Tech
use cases and and the pain points that
require longer cycles of development and
and prototyping but what what are those
what are some of those key key uh you
know pains in in the health industry
that that you're really curious about so
a lot of it is about taking Healthcare
to the
homes so doing diagnostics at home
rather than go to the clinic for
instance you know a simple device that
will measure if the baby has an ear
infection and if you're a parent uh you
know that babies tend to get he
infections but they can't speak they
can't tell you to just cry endlessly and
there is no way to solve this unless you
go to the physician who with the right
with the autoscope can look into the ear
and see and that is not accurate imagine
you have a device that give you a full
validated answer at home so then all you
need to do is is to get the right
medication and and we have a few example
of of these type of devices we have um
you know home blood test machine uh we
have a few devices that can do
prediction of
um um migrant prediction of COPD uh to
you know rise ups and so forth um and
it's all about taking healthare from the
clinics from the expensive areas to the
home to make it more accessible and so
if you're looking at what's happening
today in the worlds of predictive or
generative AI in the context of deep
Tech medical devices whether it's at at
home Diagnostics or or other elements
what's the bridge because a lot of times
I think we're looking at you know what's
happening in the predictive or
generative VI and we're looking at very
much you know software based you know
productivity
llms I know that there's a lot of really
fascinating work in the context of
mental health and and tele Health how
how where are the big elements that you
see now are shifting or catalyzing as a
result of what's happening so healthare
is moving slowly right and if you
develop something with AI which all of
them do today right it's it's a very
common tool and people are using AI it's
a very general and wide you know title
AI all of them use some types of AI not
very much use generative AI but they use
mostly deep learning or machine learning
in order to develop the algorithms that
will get to the results so at first in
most cases the first application will be
uh decision support something that will
help the
physician get to the decision faster or
in more reliable way the next phase will
be okay you don't need an expert
physician if up till now you had to go
to the expert in order to
you know solve the situation now with
the software you can go to the
GP um or even to a technician you know
not even a physician in some cases um in
the long run it will eventually take
away complete tasks from The Physician
but it takes time the evolution is of
years it's will not you know two years
and then you know get rid of the doctor
no it takes years because we need to be
very careful it's about lives of people
there is no room for any
mistake and and you know people tend to
forget a human physician has the right
to make
mistakes an algorithm has zero tolerance
for mistake you need to be always right
let's talk a bit about the this the
mentality of the the entrepreneur in in
your space one of the elements that you
know when you ask
many VCS in in software and and B2B
Enterprise and consumer you you hear
them saying you know some
characteristics of the entrepreneur
they're looking for are are impatience
stubbornness move fast break things
there's this Persona of of what it means
to be in sort of this software race
today it sounds like from from in in
your world entrepre the entrepreneurial
nature the and the the
Behavior may have different elements to
it because we're talking about longer
cycles and we're talking about different
elements how do you how do you see sort
of this Persona of the entrepreneurs in
your space what are the characteristics
that make up for a successful
entrepreneur that can go the whole
endtoend journey in in what sounds to be
a very complicated
flow the flow is complicated and and you
you need to be well aware of the stages
that you need to go through and if you
take you know a a software guy and put
him in in front on top of of a you know
medical device company he'll probably
fail because he'll move too fast he'll
go to the market without the product
being ready or being validated in the
proper way um so it can kill a company
if you go too fast and we've seen the
examples um so you need to have the
balance you need to have on on the one
hand the impatience the energy um you
know someone who will always run as fast
as possible
but needs to know you know there are
things you cannot overcome FDA is FDA
you don't play with it you have to do it
right uh same for the CE right it's the
same in Europe um but be creative you
know in some cases perhaps you have a
use case where you can you know go on a
wellness route so you don't need a um a
full uh FDA clearance because you don't
claim to do anything it's just a
wellness device Dev and you know use it
for your own Wellness if you like you
can enjoy it you don't promise anything
then you can do it but you need to be
very careful how you do it not to block
yourself from going into the medical
device field
eventually um so you need to be very
much aware of all the obstacles
interesting if you're if you have to
think back to some
some anecdotes or or instances in which
you know you were surprised at at this
work um particularly in in the
transition to to to investing or from
software to to health what what were
some elements that you had to sort of do
a mind shift or rearrange your train of
thought ER or retrain yourself to
rethink in this
industry one interesting I remember um
that you know thought that came through
to me one day we started to deal with
digital Therapeutics
okay and dig Therapeutics sounds very
complicated if you're going to use a
software in order to cure an
illness it has to be you know super
smart super accurate and you imagine
that the barrier is going to be much
higher than doing Diagnostics yeah in
essence it's the other way around if you
think about it when you diagnose you
need to be able to diagnose all cases
all the time in the right way there is
no room for any mistake now if you have
a digital Therapeutics for lower lower
back
pain and you can only help 30% of the
population it's a big
win it's a big win it's huge yeah so
digital Therapeutics is actually easier
than
Diagnostics and and for me it was
counterintuitive tell me more about this
it's it's interesting so we have this
one company that was developed by this
uh
PhD U that is doing physical therapy for
back pains and he was doing that in his
own office for many many years and
eventually he came and and said okay we
can make this automated because he came
to the conclusion that many of the back
pains are created because you don't
stand in a very symmetric
way um so he developed a device that you
wear on your body and have some sensors
and you walk on a treadmill and it will
measure the
symmetric symmetric of of your body see
if you're working in a symmetric way or
perhaps you're leaning to one end or
another end so that's the de the part
that will say okay this is the problem
and then it will try and fix it by uh
putting pressure on your body in the
right place and let you work and the
pressure will fix your
position and in a series of short
trainings it will cure your ill your
pain now it will not cure the pain of
everyone with lower back
pain but everyone who suffer from lower
back pain has no no way of of of solving
it other than painkillers so they will
be willing to try it and if it will help
for you know 30% of the population we
have a big winner in our hand yeah it's
it's it's huge so this is now in
clinical trials and after the clinical
trials we will get the regulation
approval and then we can go and try and
start selling it yeah okay it's going to
be much faster than a diagnostic device
that will do a blood test at home or you
know other devices that we have you you
said a sentence before that I want to
look back to um that humans human
Physicians can make errors algorithms
cannot in terms of at least expectation
right it's a it's a matter of a and I
you know I'm thinking in parallel to
self-driving cars and how know we we we
see and and it's always been fascinating
to me sort of this this decision-making
process of of a of being you know making
the decision to make that transition
with enough evidence that that you're
aiding so why is that why do we have
that there do you agree with that by the
way do you agree that this should be the
state of mind do you think it should be
different no I think it has to be this
state of mind because you know
Physicians are human beings and human
beings can make mistakes a physician if
you take them to court they will have to
prove that they reviewed all the data
and that they followed you know the the
golden lines of how how this practice is
being done and if they did it and got to
the wrong decision that's okay they're
human they're allowed to make this
mistake because they were following the
the you know the guidelines that were by
I don't know the association of of this
expert or not um otherwise they will not
be able to make any decision because
there always mistakes okay um if you
train an algorithm on a certain input
and this algorithm is right only in some
cases how can you trust it how can you
use it it has to be accurate all the
time if I want to diagnose I don't know
this ear infection and I'm wrong and you
gave a baby antibiotics for no reason
mhm and this problem I don't know God
forbid God Wars and the kid was very ill
and hospitalized and and let's stop
here it's a huge B it's a big deal it's
a huge problem unless perhaps you're
able to explain the train of thought and
the evidence and the data which was used
to in in in line similarly to how
perhaps a physician would make a
decision so it sounds to me like there
is an element of of of of expressing
what was the ethical and coherent
decision-making process that as long as
you follow the guidelines it's okay to
be wrong how do we how do we Implement
that same explainability and and similar
framework to to to an algorithm right
you're right and then remember that in
some cases it's the difference between
Art and Science still yeah okay and
expert physician is a Craftman okay he
he knows by heart he can look at the ear
and get to the solution to the decision
immediately and there is no recording of
the ear so yep nobody can question that
an algorithm you'll have to prove that
the algorithm was right and if it's
based on AI the algorithm is a black box
you don't even know yep um and I and I
hope for us that we're able to open up
that black box because
just like we've seen in you know in llms
and and predictive AI we're saying that
there's massive efforts to unbox this
black box to be able to tell okay this
is where we got our data from this is
how we came to the conclusions T we can
go on this for hours but I really want
to appreciate your time and thank you
for for spending this time with me I
think that the space that you're in is
is incredibly fascinating it's
effectively one of the most important
things we're doing obviously for for
Humanity um the the it's the pains that
you're looking at and the opportunities
I think they're not just nice to have
they're you know they're really
fundamentally changing how people
experience their life and
so I'm it it sounds amazing and we
didn't even get to talk about your the
amazing work that you've also done with
gam the work I want to make one comment
if if you have 30
seconds people always ask me how will AI
affect the the job of the Physicians and
will there will they lose a job or not
yeah and and people don't realize the
the amazing shortage of healthcare
providers or Healthcare experts we have
all around the world there are not
enough Physicians to take care of all
the population the new babies and
especially the older guys we are all
getting old and there are not enough
Physicians to take care of everyone we
can only hope that Ai and Technology
will make the physician more efficient
so we can treat the entire population
with the same Manpower that we have
today and I'm not sure it will be it
could be that today we are at the peak
of the quality of healthcare years to
come it's a it's quite quite a thought
to leave
with Hello thank you so much thank you
[Music]